un accueil de jour pour les personnes
atteintes de maladies neuro évolutive
c'est ce que propose l'association xxi
mais pas que une plateforme existe pour
accompagner les aidants objectif
prévenir le risque d'épuisement
on peut accepter un aidant à partir du
moment où il ya une conjointe ou un cd
qui a une maladie neuro évolutive ou à
partir du moment où la personne a plus
de 60 ans et est en perte d'autonomie
des ateliers à destination des aidants
sont proposés au programme bien-être
promenade dans la forêt de rambouillet
ou encore ateliers de coaching pour
échanger ce sont des aidants qui se
retrouvent ensemble
animée par un psychologue et l'idée
c'est de parler donc une première séance
de sa situation et en fait les autres
vont aborder des sujets allant mais
pourquoi t'as pas penser à ça ou tiens
tu pourrais peut-être penser à ça parce
que moi je détestais ça marche va donner
des pistes en fait pour que la personne
puisse trouver des solutions sur sa
situation
la plateforme d'accompagnement vise à
soutenir les aidants dont la charge
mentale est importante
un besoin qui s'est fait ressentir le
coc vida pas aider les aidants se sent
votre vaisselle au domicile
ça a été une vraie catastrophe pour pour
eux et pour les personnes du coup
atteint de maladie north évolutive donc
on voit vraiment l'importance de la
plateforme on voit vraiment l'importance
de l'accueil de jour aussi pour les
aidants l'accueil de jour de rambouillet
à la recherche de bénévoles pour
renforcer son équipe en moyenne une
cinquantaine de personnes sollicitées la
plateforme d'accompagnement des aidants